[Música]
Eu não vejo o futuro, o presente, o futuro e agora
na sua talvez tenhamos a ver com o
tempos com os anjos são com o tempo
com nossa experiência de atemporalidade
Eu quero falar um pouco mais sobre esses
três vezes e também alguns outros
hora grega
podemos ajudar a pensar ou apresentar
uma coisa que eu gostaria que você fosse
romper com o cronos
e que cronos não apresenta crono no passado
porque o número do movimento cronos
kronos é um número que passa em um
movimento sucessivo
o máximo que você tem em mente em cronos e
agora em um instante
kristen estandes está isento de
intervalo
concordo um par de horas
há sempre uma hora
uau agora que ele está prestes a viver e eles jejuaram
pronunciamos aqui já pronunciamos
bem passado e em crans ou passado ocre
futuros estão caindo cada vez menos
Durado
cada mistura
mais passado e presente do que nunca
instantâneo
para um presente maior
naqueles tempos credos permanecem
ir para isso
há um círculo em um tempo que dura em
uma vida que a paz é um presente que é
prolongar que não pare isso como se
foi a duração de uma vida sem
movimento
é uma experiência
hora da dança
tempo de remendo tempo de reprodução
som
tempo de pensamento
o tempo de uma criação que salta
criar ou saltar
é preciso apresentar
criar dança
ou pensar no passado no futuro
embora cronos ela completamente hoje ele
é muito comum para muitas coisas
cronos e ciência do tempo
as instituições que nos organizam, mas
permite que todos nós sejamos aumentados
vídeo suficiente 1656 e todos nós sabemos por que
eles estão pagando
conhece o tempo da ciência
medicina por exemplo tão importante
ato
temos que fazer
14 dias de 40 anos
se não tivéssemos cronos como faríamos
reaparecer
como faríamos sem teríamos
majes odeiam a américa
consideraríamos tomar unidos
mim
mas nos organiza
É um problema de cronos e que cronos
onde presente em cronos para muitas coisas
que você não pode ir passear eu quero falar
um pouco de um tempo nosso
hora grega porque uma hora que tal
vez que ela
crucialmente importante
que o tempo de educação bem que não
ser outra palavra para ritmo
talvez várias palavras para fofo do que o
três cronos caídos
'estamos ao quarto do que eles são
vozes
entrar atraiu os outros porque também
Se eu disser todas as palavras, qual é a
gordura desse timeshare
para a mesma palavra prática
então se estiver errado eles ficam surpresos
a palavra é velha
você sabe o que significa es co les escoles
significa tempo livre
conhecer
como os latinos traduziram es cole
por 88 Levante termina lazer
também significa tempo livre
graus são o latim
e gregor aceitou nossa palavra
escola
venha
acho que não amigo
a palavra escola
paulo e os gregos quando criaram
escolas
eles chamaram
tem um político eles não criaram escolas como
espaços de aprendizagem
não é necessário você precisa de uma escola
para aprender
pode ser aprendido em qualquer lugar
se uma escola é necessária
ter tempo livre para liberar ou
clima
para que as obrigações que sim não e
ver uma escola que não podíamos, mas o tempo
gratuitamente
tem
as sociedades de notas são ditas e somoto
ou o tempo vale ouro
um tempo justo
não podemos perder o que
por tempo e dinheiro
e o mesmo se não for trabalhamos temos
para justificar o que produzimos para
aquele salário severo 20 para feito isso
Eles foram criados
com que foram criados
para liberar o tempo
sociedade da produtividade e exige
ter escola ou tempo livre e podemos
dedicar tempo
estudar para pensar em todos aqueles
coisas que fazemos sobre nós mesmos e não
cabelo que eles produzem
é um lugar para
christina pensa embora autoridade
Eu sei o que a escola faz, sou eu
são muitas instituições diferentes
Eu sei que hoje você não pode perder isso
então
o contrário
ou aquele que se aprende crescendo
outra coisa para ver
agora escola ou para encontrar um
lugar não mercado de trabalho
a fila se tornou uma instituição
disciplinador moderno e produtor de
sujeitos de um sistema
Capitalista como vivemos atualmente
quantas escolas
não muito tempo atrás não havia instituições com
tempo cronológico e
sou
Coronado não governou
as escolas das instituições do
campo livre liberado
para que os alunos
encontrar-se em um mundo
sobre a mesa e que nasci porque
vivemos esse mundo
em que outros mundos poderíamos viver
um mundo mais justo um mundo menor
exclusivo
- escravo menos
aqui estou eu em tais novas instituições
porque as escolas hoje
Eu vivo em outro tempo um tempo que aqui
eu sou se conseguirmos
recuperar esse tempo livre
que é salão naquele momento
aquele ou próprio tempo de educação e não o
inclusão
aqui estou eu se pelos prédios
escolares em qualquer lugar
podemos evitar um tempo livre
tempo liberado
o futuro e o tempo passado
Presente
tempo das crianças
como uma educação que fornece o infinito
gravidade da parentalidade confirma
infelizmente hoje nas escolas chinesas
aumentando seu tempo
cronologia eles são amigos
talvez nesse sentido hoje vai ser
escola significa infantil habilidoso
para fazer a memória semear o tempo
antes de
você um bom presente de queijo albino
agora isso
e ajuste
e 16 e bosh é
me acompanhe nesse tempo livre e um
escola
minha intervenção como um deleite
kronos kairos e ayo
tempos gregos
com vídeos que ou outra vez
tempo de saída do buraco da scola
ou tempo livre ou tempo daqui o que
eu fiz foi por isso eu não por outra coisa
tempo e uma antiga fila, mas escola 24
tempo de uma vida
que falhou com uma vida de pura presa
complicado